the cathedral is a basilica that's to
say it has a long boat like quality
intersected by a transept with the
steeple rising up above and then to the
west a little Western frontispiece at
first sight the Cathedral looks
architectural unified but when we look a
little harder we can see important
differences between the nave to the
right and the choir to the layout the
nave is capped by a horizontal
balustrade unbroken but the choir has a
balustrade broken by gables the nave has
solid flying buttresses the choir as
openwork flying buttresses these are
signs that chronological signs because
the nave was built before the choir the
nave we can associate with the work of
the initial architect robert of massage
followed by thomas of komal whereas the
upper choir was only built a decade or
so later by Thomas's son who his name
was run home